So
was a couple of things I want to tell
you about today.
Many things I want to tell you about.
I want to tell you,
um,
give you a schema that's going to enable
you to understand.
I think it will enable you to understand
stories like the one I told you last
time you remember Jonah and the whale.
I want to provide you with this Schema
so that you can understand stories like
that.
But many,
many more stories like that.
And partly what I'm telling you about
today,
in some sense our archetypes and there's
a vr and an archetype isn't,
it's an idea that was made most popular
over the last hundred years by Carl
Young,
but it's a much older idea that not,
it's really a platonic ideas.
And in some ways,
and it means it means something like
fundamental pattern.
And so an architect can manifest itself
in different ways.
It could be a pattern of emotional
response.
So that could be something that you're
feeling.
It could be the way that that emotional
response displays itself on your body,
on your face.
It could be the way that that emotion
fields and displays itself on your face
and then plays itself out as a drama in
your local environment.
So like an angry argument is an
architect will phenomenon.
And the reason it's archetipal is
because,
well,
you have one them,
you have them,
everyone has them.
And so you can't really think about them
as individual.
You have to think about them as
universal and you can't think about them
as something that you create in a sense,
although in a sense you do,
but also as something that happens to
you.
Now,
when you read about young and
archetypes,
it's quite confusing because you can
never be sure whether he's talking about
an instinct and emotion,
a motivational system or a
subpersonality or the subpersonality
within which those things manifest
itself,
or even the social drama that's being
played out in time and space in the
social world.
But our real archetype,
I would say is all of those things at
the same time.
Now we use archetipal means of
expression to represent how we act.
And that's not the same thing as resent
representing what the world is made out
of.
It's a very different thing and so you
could say in some sense,
we tell stories and understand stories
so that we can figure out how people act
and how they should act and then we
conduct science so that we can figure
out what the world's like from a
material objective perspective and the
two things coexist on easily.
I think the more primary form of
knowledge is actually how to act with
the scientific model nested inside it
because it's the most important question
that you have to solve as a living
organism isn't what the world is made
out of.
It's how you should act in the world,
say from a Darwinian perspective even so
that you can live long enough to
reproduce.
That's basically from a strict
biological perspective.
In some sense.
That's what you have to do in order to
be successful.
It's kind of obvious,
first of all,
because you're not very successful if
you just go and die.
And then of course death from a genetic
perspective and failing to leave
offspring are much the same thing.
So
now one of the questions might be how is
it that we conceive of the world as a
place to act in?
And that's partly,
I'm going to outline a hypothesis for
you and then explain the significance of
that hypothesis.
And the hypothesis involves the
description of what you might consider
constituent elements and also
transformation processes.
Okay.
So as far as I can tell,
the constituent elements of the stories
that we tell about how people act and
should act our characters.
Now that makes sense,
right?
Because you really can't have a drama or
a story without characters.
Now the thing is the characters have to
be understandable.
And so for them to be understandable,
they sort of have to be like you or they
have to be like someone that you know,
but they have to be human.
But then again,
it's not exactly that they're human.
Because even when you're telling a story
about what happened to you today,
it's interesting to think about what you
do.
So someone might say,
well,
how was your day?
And you say,
fine.
I mean maybe that's the lowest level,
lowest resolution,
highest abstract story.
My Day was fine.
It's pretty boring story.
It's better than terrible,
I suppose,
but it's,
it's not interesting and it's not
detailed,
but person gets the notion that things
went according to what according to plan
or more specifically the things unfolded
the way he wanted them to,
just not exactly the same as according
to plan because a plan is kind of a cold
cognitive thing,
you know,
or or,
or expectation,
expectation.
The cognitive scientists sort of use
weather well while what you,
how you wanted them to implies that you
have desires and emotions and
motivations and that they inform the way
that you're acting in the world because
you don't just act in the world,
you act in the world so that you've
tried to turn it into something better
than it is right now.
Assuming you have any sense,
you know,
because some people act on the world to
make it worse than it is now,
but we're going to forget about those
people for now.
So when you say find someone,
you basically say,
roughly speaking,
I got what I wanted today without undue
hassle.
Okay.
So
that's a really condensed version of the
events of the day.
And it's not a very good story,
although it might suffice for casual
conversation.
Person might say,
no,
no.
What did you do today?
And then maybe you'll say,
oh,
I woke up this morning and I went to
university.
And uh,
you know,
the subway took a lot longer than it
usually does.
And so,
you know,
I used that to do some studying and then
I got to school at night.
I particularly don't lecture,
but lunch was really good and I met some
friends.
And so that's kind of a story,
right?
And you,
the person that you're talking to do,
might listen to you.
It's not a particularly compelling
story,
but it's probably better than fine.
And you might say,
well,
why did you select those elements to
talk about?
You know,
you didn't talk about how many times you
blinked your eyes.
The,
the first minute that you woke up and
you didn't describe the motor movements
that you use to put your left leg on the
floor and you didn't describe,
you know what bowl you used for
breakfast.
And the reason you didn't do that is
because a,
you don't remember for whatever reason,
and B,
you don't care and neither does have
your listener.
But that's the peculiar things that your
listener is going to care about some
things and not care about other things.
And if you're a good storyteller,
you kind of automatically know which of
those things that you should talk about
so that you're interested in which of
the things you should ignore it so that
you're not boring your listener to
death.
And you also understand that they will
also understand them,
but you don't know how you do that.
All you know is that you're trying to
tell an interesting story.
And in some sense what you're doing is
you're trying to reduce a sequence of
actions and conceptions of exceptional
complexity to the just right,
which is like the essential or the moral
in some sense.
And you're trying to convey that.
And the other person is listening partly
because they want to indicate that they
care for you.
And we'd like to know,
they want to stay caught up with your
ongoing narrative so that they
understand you.
And maybe also because they might think
that they'll garner some,
you know,
bit of information factual or behavioral
that might aid them in some way,
you know,
so,
and we're doing that to each other all
the time and we automatically do this.
We automatically know how to tell
stories.
And so what I'm saying is that even the
person that you describe when you
describe yourself to someone else isn't
exactly you.
It's some representation of you as a
sort of generic human being that's going
about doing certain kinds of interesting
things in the world.
Or here's a way of thinking about it
roughly is that you make yourself the
hero of your own story.
And so you kind of know that because
when you go to a movie and movies are
usually romances,
say or hero stories,
we'll romances or adventures or both,
roughly speaking.
Um,
you know,
and sometimes they turn out well and
that's a comedy and sometimes they don't
turn out so well.
And that's a tragedy.
But when you go there,
what you basically see as a story about
another person who sort of like you,
who's the hero and what you do is you
track them through a sequence of
adventures.
And usually what you track them through
isn't things were good and then they
stayed good.
And then at the end they were still the
same as they were at the beginning.
And good.
You know,
because why do you want to watch that?
And you might say,
well you should because isn't that
pleasant?
The person's happy and then they stay
happy and then they end happy and
everyone's happy.
It's why.
Why isn't that interesting?
But it isn't.
And really what want to see is you
either see,
you want to see someone get into trouble
and fail in a spectacularly interesting
way,
or you want to see someone get into
trouble and then overcome it in a
spectacularly interesting way.
And so there's this idea in the,
in the story that the person has to
undergo some kind of transformation in
the midst of their travails and efforts
in order for it to be interesting.
So they have to start in one place,
they have to end up somewhere that's not
so good in a very,
very complicated way.
And then maybe by transforming nerve,
their character by transforming the
surroundings are bread coming to some
sort of realization or maybe just by dim
wit and luck,
they managed to solve the set of
problems that emerge triumphant at the
other end.
All right,
so that's the meaning of Jonah and the
whale.
Or you remember what happens to Jonah is
that he's got this destiny he supposed
to be pursuing.
Any decides that it's too much trouble?
Well,
not unsurprisingly,
because if you remember what he was told
to do was go to tale a whole city that
they were misbehaving,
assuming rightly as he did that that
would not make him pretty particularly
park popular and maybe he'd get killed
and even if he didn't,
it would be extraordinarily difficult.
He thought,
there's no damn way I'm doing that.
So he denied his destiny and as a
consequence he fell into the abyss and
was swallowed up.
And then because he repented and decided
to carry on with what he was to carry on
with his responsibilities,
the creature of the abyss spit them back
up and he got to go along his merry way.
Now you might say,
well,
nothing like that has ever happened to
you,
but that's wrong.
Things like that happen to all the time
and you know it.
So here,
here,
here's a couple of examples and you'll
be able to draw all sorts of examples
from your own life.
Okay?
That's a story of betrayal.
For example,
maybe in one of your relatively
uninformed
no
salaries,
you ended up establishing a relationship
with someone who was really not good for
you.
And that might mean while they just,
it was just a bad personality match or
it might mean they really weren't good
for you because you know,
you could get pretty unlucky and you can
get tangled up with someone who's very
deceitful and very malevolent and who
could care less about your maybe who
even wants to hurt you.
And then you can establish a trusting
relationship with them.
Or at least you trust them.
And then one day,
you know,
you find out that they are not who they
said they weren't.
Or even more importantly,
they are not who you thought they were.
And so then maybe you're in a committed
relationship and they'd be trey you with
someone else.
And so then you think,
well,
there you are at home and you're,
you know,
you're perfectly happy about being at
home and then your partner comes home
and for one reason or now that you find
out that they're having an affair or
that they'd be trained you or that
they'd lied to you.
And some other spectacularly important
way.
And maybe it's a lover and maybe it's a
family member,
maybe it's a sibling and maybe it's a
friend,
whatever.
It doesn't matter.
And so here's the way of thinking about
it.
The minute before they come home,
you're in one place and you remember a
place isn't just a place,
right?
A place as a place in time.
Because we live in space time,
we live in time and place.
And what that means is you can be in the
same place in one minute and a
completely different place in the next
minute,
even if you haven't even moved.
And so place is a very,
very complicated idea.
So you're sitting at home and you're
watching oprah and you're perfectly
content to do that.
And then the person comes home and the
bottom of your world falls out and then
all of a sudden you're not where you
thought you were and it's a really weird
place that you are now because it's not
where you were,
that's for sure.
But you also don't know where it is
because you don't know who that person
is that's in that room with you.
You don't know what your past with them
was or what it meant or anything else
about it because it was predicated on
absolute misperceptions.
So none of your memories about those
events are valid,
even though you have them as memories.
And then you have a worst problem,
which is if you're betrayed badly
enough,
not only are you not going to understand
your immediate past with that person,
oh,
and by the way,
your future's also gone.
So that's a big problem as is.
Your presence has become radically more
complex,
but it's worse than that because if
you're really be trained,
you're also going to think,
who am I that I could be that stupid?
And then you're going to think,
what is a human being that they can be
that corrupt.
And so not only at have has the,
have the fundamentals being kicked out
of the substructure of your perceptions,
but your notion of what it means to be
you and what it needs to be human
might've been seriously disrupted.
And you know,
the thing about that is that's a
nontrivial event.
People call that traumatic it didn't
like and it,
and it's like a physical wound.
And in fact it has,
certainly if the trauma's great enough,
it can produce a psychophysiological
wound because that sort of trauma,
a deep betrayal is a good example,
will damage your brain and maybe you'll
recover from it and maybe you won't.
And one of the ways that that's being
represented forever in mythological
stories is by being swallowed up by a
subterranean beast.
It's something that comes up from the
depths and pulls you down and then
you're in it.
Now why is that?
Well,
that's an extraordinarily complicated
question.
But here,
here's the answer.
As nearly as I can tell,
we evolved a very complicated
neuropsychological system to signal
alarm.
So that's anxiety threat,
the threat sensitive,
right.
And that makes us freeze for example.
And when you look at how an animal uses
that system,
let's say a mammal,
just to keep it simple cause we're all
mammals and so we can kind of understand
mammals.
So if a rabbit sees a wolf for example,
it's going to freeze so that the wolf
can't see it.
And if I,
if a rack smells a cat,
even if it has never smelled a cow in
its whole life,
it's going to also freeze.
And interestingly with rats,
if you put rats in a natural
environment,
which means they get to help little rap
dominance,
hierarchies,
little rat families,
they're not like little white rats,
a logan a cage,
they're happy family rats and they've
got their burrows and they live in their
little societies that maybe there is a
part of their territory where they can
go get food and they're used to that.
So those scary out there in the day kind
of hiding because they don't like light
or maybe they'll scurry out at night
cause rats are night things and they'll
get their food and they'll eat it or
bring it back or whatever they,
whatever they do,
share it with their family or at least
bring it back.
Well let's say that you put a cat out
there or maybe you even just put it out
there and take it away so that the place
smells like cat.
Well one of those rocks goes out there
and sees that cat.
First of all,
it's going to freeze and it is not a
happy thing because imagine you're a rat
and a thing that's four times as big as
a lion suddenly appears on your front
yard.
It's like,
that's rough,
man.
You're going to freeze and then you're
going to go hike downstairs and what are
you going to do?
Well,
if you're a rat,
you're going to screen for 24 hours,
which is nonstop with your little beak
poking out of your borough so everyone
can hear you scream.
And that's the same given the length of
robots,
life as you screaming nonstop for two
weeks.
So like that rats nervous,
it's not happy about the whole cap
thing.
And then maybe,
maybe if no more cat odor happens by and
no hypervigilant rat see any more cats
than after it screens for two weeks.
It starts to calm down a little bit and
maybe then it starts to remember that
it's hungry and that you know,
there's things to attend to and so then
maybe it very,
very carefully goes back out where it
was foraging for food,
sort of crouched over and hypervigilant
and not moving very much in case that
damn cats around.
And then maybe slowly it regains control
over its territory.
It runs back and forth trying to ensure
that none of that place that used to be
safe has got troublesome cats associated
with it anymore.
And so in some sense the bottom fell out
of that box life.
Now the thing is the rat has predator
detection systems that are associated
with extreme anxiety and escape.
They're automatically activated whenever
there's a Predator in site and we have
those systems too.
But human beings are.
You might say,
well,
okay,
rats have predators,
enemies,
humans have predators,
entities.
Okay,
so then we might say,
well,
what's a human predator slash?
Enemy?
Well,
it depends on how long a period of time
over which you wish to calculate what
constitutes human.
Because we know,
for example,
that 60 million years ago,
your primary Predator when you were
wandering around in trees,
and we're only about this big with
snakes,
and so snake is a Predator and an enemy
and you know,
you guys can easily learn how to be
afraid of snakes and maybe you're
innately afraid of them to begin with.
No one.
The science on that is not exactly
clear,
although it's certainly indicates that
you can easily learn snake fear.
And a probably indicates that really
it's innate.
It's innate in chimpanzees.
So why not?
It knocks,
you know,
it's not that long.
Since we split off the evolutionary
pathway from the common chimp human
ancestor,
so enemies,
snakes.
What else?
How about crocodiles?
Most things pulled a lot of your
ancestors,
well not your ancestors do.
They got pulled under water,
but when we were wandering around on the
African Veldt and we went down to the
river to have some water,
you can be sure that a fair number of us
got pulled underneath by crocodiles.
And so crocodiles and you know,
those are creepy things.
Crocodiles,
hey,
it'd be,
they figure it nightmares and they
figure in horror movies.
And you can imagine yourself in Florida
out there with alligators.
And I'm thinking,
you know,
it'd be just as well if they didn't come
too close to your boat with their little
beady eyes.
And they're great big teeth that,
you know,
they're unpleasant things.
And then there's lions,
hyenas.
Okay.
And those are,
what are those things?
You might think a lion in a hygiene or
different things,
but they're not,
I would say they're large tooth
mammalian carnivores.
It's like a medic category.
And so they sort of fit in that Predator
enemy category.
And your nervous system is prepared to
respond to predatory eyes and teeth.
And no wonder because predatory eyes
track you down at teeth,
eat you at a bite,
you.
And so it's a good thing that you're
aware of those and that you can detect
them rapidly.
Um,
yeah.
What else is a human enemy?
How about another human?
How would that be?
You think more people have died from
other humans are from predators.
All right.
Well,
I suspect that since we'd actually been
human,
if that's maybe 150,000 years,
because that's about when it appears
that we were more or less genetically
identical to what we are now.
My guess is that humans have got it all
over predators.
I mean,
lots of us,
God eat and let's not be too shy about
discussing that,
but now at least,
man,
it's other people.
Okay,
well what about yourself?
How about you as your own enemy?
Then you can make it psychological.
Maybe it's not other people may,
but it's the evil in their hearts for
maybe it's an evil in your hearts.
So you see,
so this is the way of thinking about is
that we have a circuit to deal with
threats,
but the threats exist all the way from
the primordial biological,
like actual predators like snakes all
the way up to the incredibly abstract.
Like my great enemy is the evil
intentions that other people harbored
towards me or that maybe I have in my
own heart.
Okay?
So that's that entire complex of
predatory slash threat.
Slash.
Evil because it's become psychologists
to that point.
That's one of the things that can be a
character in a movie.
And it is,
right?
It's the antagonist.
It's the adversary that's the,
that's the archetypal element.
It's the thing that opposes you would
every way.
And you can locate that and all sorts of
different places,
right?
You could have a story about how someone
is grappling with their own evil
impulses up.
What's the name of that serial killer
thing?
Um,
Dexter Dexter's got that problem.
People are pretty fascinated by that
show,
right?
A serial killer who can do good,
like sort of like a human being in some
sense,
you know?
So Dexter's got this psychological
battle between good and evil in his
heart,
or maybe the,
maybe the,
the enemy is externalized.
So maybe it's Batman and the joker and
the joker is a pretty,
the joker is really a figure of,
of chaotic evil fundamentally,
you know,
in the Best Batman movie,
which was the one with,
uh,
well with the joker and it wasn't Jack
Nicholson who played the,
yeah,
yeah.
Heath Ledger,
you know,
that was rough on old heath and no
wonder,
you know,
cause he embodied this architectural
character and that joker was so much of
an adversary that he didn't even want to
win.
Right?
You can understand the adversaries that
want to win.
It's adversaries that want to make
everyone lose,
that are really hard to understand.
And that's part of what made that movie,
you know,
relatively striking and memorable.
And he really embodied that character.
Well.
And so one,
here's two sets of characters that make
up stories,
heroin,
adversary.
Okay?
So,
and you can,
you can understand that at multiple
levels simultaneously.
Um,
here's another set of characters.
Now,
here's why I think these characters are
fundamental elements of our cognitive
structure called a cognitive
substructure.
First of all,
I think that really what we want to
know,
it's not what it is,
but we want to know how to act,
how to conduct ourselves in the world.
We're moving creatures,
right?
You don't just sit there on a rock and
filter seawater through our guilt.
We have to go out there and contend with
the world,
and so we need to know how to do that.
We need to know how to do it and how not
to do it.
So we can look for good examples and we
can look for bad examples.
We don't want just any old good example.
We want a good example that's boiled
right down to excellent example and we
want a bad example that's boiled right
down to excellent,
bad example.
And so a good example would be a
character who is an amalgam of all the
good things about good people and an
evil character would be an announcement
of all the evil things about bad people
and the more pure in some sense in
essence,
both of those characters are the more
architectural of the story.
And so an architectural story,
he's good versus evil.
And you might think you don't believe in
good versus evil,
but it doesn't really matter what you
believe.
Because when you go to movies,
you watched that and you watch it as if
you believe it.
And I would say this is an existential
claim by the way,
is that it doesn't matter what you say
you believe,
because what do you know about it?
What matters is how you act out what you
believe.
And if you really want to find out what
you believe,
you don't ask yourself what you believe.
You Watch yourself act and you deduce
from that what you believe.
And so if you don't believe,
for example,
in a good versus evil archetipal
struggle,
then what are you doing?
Watching wars,
for example.
Okay.
Because obviously that's an archetypal
story,
just like every partner is an archetypal
story.
And both of those are archetypal stories
about good versus evil.
Okay.
Next set of categories.
So imagine that we've been living in
familial groups for who knows how long,
let's say 3 million years.
Just for the sake of argument.
We were living in tribal groups way,
way longer than that.
You know,
if you think about a tribal group is
something that might extend back farther
than chimpanzees were living in
dominance hierarchies for way longer
than tribal groups.
But the family group,
you got to think we'd be living in
family groups for about as long as we've
been extraordinarily dependent as
infants and as long as we've had really
large brains.
And so again,
that's,
you can't draw,
you know,
pipe line.
But because we'd been getting bigger and
bigger brains for quite a long time,
but it's,
it's in the millions of years,
let's say.
And so,
and the other thing that you might think
about is that you know,
your cognitive apparatus,
your perceptual apparatus,
you're emotional apparatus has
originated within an environment.
Obviously now we tend to think of the
environment as the natural environment
and then we tend to think of the natural
environment is like a forest.
But the natural environment for
propriety,
nate's say is only for us to some
degree.
I mean,
first of all we,
we didn't just dwell in forests because
we were also veldt dwelling creatures.
But also we,
we didn't really dwell among trees.
We dwelled among other primates like us.
And so our primary environment is
actually other people.
And then you might say,
okay,
what are the fundamental categories of
the other people?
Well,
how about mother?
That's a big one because the probability
that you had a mother,
it's like it's up there at about a
hundred percent you know?
And if there wasn't,
even if you're,
if you lost your biological mother at
birth,
if someone didn't fulfill the archetipal
role of mother,
then you don't live.
And that,
that doesn't just mean providing you
with food and water and shelter.
Because if you provide a child under f
one with food and water and shelter and
that's it,
they die.
You have to pick them up.
You have to touch them,
you have to rock the back and forth.
You have to communicate with them.
If you don't give them physical
attention,
their nervous systems shut down and they
die.
And so that's part of the reason why in
well in eastern European orphanages,
orphanages before the wall fell down,
the death rate,
especially in places like Romania in the
orphanages,
it's an awful story,
was unbelievably high.
And if the kids didn't die,
they were just so crippled
psychologically that they never
recovered.
And that was because people didn't touch
them and didn't interact with them.
And so you need a creature playing out
the architectural role of mother to
entice you into life.
Otherwise you just perish.
So mother,
that's a category man.
And then,
well for others,
the category two,
and it's the same thing,
applies there.
And even if you don't have a farther,
there's a male power structure around
you,
a dominance heart,
they roughly speaking,
that acts in the paternal role.
And there's no getting away from that
unless you don't live in a society.
And then if you don't live in a society,
then you just died because you can't
live by yourself.
So father and mother are primary
categories.
And then there's the primary category of
the individual because wherever you are,
there you are.
And that's been the case for every human
being that's ever existed.
So the fundamental categories are
individual,
mother and father.
Well,
and there's another fundamental category
which we alluded to,
which is horrible thing that lives at
the bottom of a pit that will devour you
and that has a psychological reality and
uh,
objective reality.
And that's,
as I said,
that's equivalent to the story of Jonah
being gobbled up by the whale that
happens.
That sort of stories.
Very Comic Pinocchio is a story like
that,
right?
Pinocchio has an existential problem.
He doesn't know how to be a real boy.
And it turns out that in order to become
a real boy,
we might regard that as a fully
developed individual.
He has to go down to the bottom of the
ocean,
into a whale and rescue his father.
Well you,
it doesn't take a lot of imagination to
see the kinship between that story and
the story of Jonah.
It's the same story.
Jonah had to reestablish his
relationship with God the father in
order to successfully make a passage
from aimless and disobedient character
to someone who was alive on shore and
pursuing a particular tie.
It's the same motif.
It's a very,
very,
very common motif.
And the reason for that is that actual
people transform,
you know,
when they hit an obstacle of some sort
that just blows them into pieces and
they go down into the depths,
into the abyss and they are,
they lived down there for a while and
it's not pleasant.
And maybe they learn something while
they're down there if they're lucky and
they get back up.
And that's the story of human
development.
You never learn something without having
something small die.
And sometimes you learn something and
something big dies and then you know,
you put yourself back together and you
pick up the pieces and you emerge
unscathed,
hopefully,
and perhaps transformed and you carry
on.
And so the human developmental story
isn't an upward march in a linear
manner.
You know,
upon even slope it's perhaps upwards and
onwards.
But it's like this,
it's punctuated by catastrophes.
And of course you guys know that because
obviously,
I mean,
how many times,
how many people in this room have been
seriously unhappy at one point in their
life for more than two weeks.
Okay.
Is there anyone who hasn't had that
experience breathing?
Yes.
Have you not had that experience?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
sorry.
I thought you raised your hand.
Has Anybody not had that experience?
Okay.
So maybe not you.
Well that's good.
Congratulations.
That's really amazing.
So it's coming,
so,
yeah.
Yeah.
So,
so the thing is,
you know,
here,
here's one way of looking at it.
That's reality.
Reality is that you're,
you're environment is punctuated by
descents.
Your pathways punctuated by descents.
And when you're asked sending,
that's one place.
And when you're descending and at the
bottom,
that's another place.
And I can tell you,
and this will help you with your
interpretation of stories,
is that the,
the times when you descend is equivalent
to a voyage.
To the underworld.
That's what a voyage to the underworld
means in mythology.
The bottom has fallen out and down you
go.
And you know this sort of thing,
because look,
if I say we're all skating on thin ice,
like is there anybody here who doesn't
know what that means?
Okay.
So what does it mean?
What does it mean
the ice could the daily,
right?
The ice can fall out in anytime and then
what happens?
Yeah.
Down you go.
Right.
And it's cold down there.
Yeah.
And maybe you don't get back up.
And it's the sort of story that sort of
sends a chill down your spine.
And it should,
because that's life.
And so one of the things that I already
like about advanced personality theory
is that it takes that into account.
It says,
yeah,
that's life.
Okay,
now that we've established that,
what do we do?
And so then it becomes something like
this.
It's not so much how do you stop
yourself from descending and ascending?
Cause good luck with that.
But since you're going to have to do
that,
how do you do it?
And so part of the reason that I called
this course personality and its
transformations is because one,
one thing that you can learn about
yourself as who you are,
and that's really useful.
But the other thing that you can learn
about yourself is how it is that you can
conduct yourself across time.
And that means you're going to have to
conduct yourself so that you can weather
storms.
And some of those might be you make a
mistake in the ice breaks,
you know?
And some of it is,
yeah,
the ice breaks and it's no mistake at
all.
It's just how it is,
you know?
So when you're one of your parents
develops Alzheimer's disease for
example,
well you can say that's your mistake
because you're not smart enough to do
anything about it,
then you know,
be a better clue in because otherwise
the disease is going to continue.
But on the other hand,
really thinking about it as a personal
fault seems inappropriate.
It's just a catastrophe that's
associated with being alive.
And that's what life is,
you know?
And so one of the things you see,
for example,
in all of the major trends of religious
thinking all around the world,
and I talk about religious thinking
because those are the deepest kinds of
stories.
That's really what makes them,
by the way,
it's always the same message.
Life is suffering.
And the reason for that is because we
skate on thin ice.
Okay?
And you can say,
well,
we should pick it up the damn ice and
fair enough,
you know?
Right.
Definitely.
But you should also prepare yourself to
swim so that when you fall in,
you don't die.
So now the job story has a hint or two
in it,
you know?
So the first thing that happens is job
is in some sense called the action.
Now,
because that's an old story because it's
a primarily Judeo Christian and
religious story.
The call cause action takes the force of
a divine command.
Right?
Now you might think,
well,
there's such a thing exist.
And it's a silly question in some ways
because whether or not something exists
depends on what you mean by exist,
you know?
And that can vary with your
philosophical presuppositions.
But it also,
it also varies on why you're asking the
question and where you're looking for
the answer.
So for example,
here's an example.
Do you believe that there are things
that you should do?
Okay,
thank you.
Is there anyone here who doesn't believe
that?
Or more importantly,
is there anyone here who doesn't act
like they believe it?
So you wake up in the morning and you
think,
God,
there's a bunch of things I should do or
there's some things I should do next
week.
Aren't there some things I should do
with my life?
Yes.
That's a common thought.
Does anyone not think that way?
Okay.
So you know,
if you're not thinking that way,
you end up pretty depressed because then
you think,
well,
there's nothing I should do with my
life.
And that's not such a happy thought
because life is hard.
And then if there's nothing to do with
this wall all year,
they're stuck with is a bunch of
suffering and that doesn't seem like a
very good idea.
Okay.
So then you might say,
well,
what exactly does should mean?
Well,
it means that you have a moral
obligation of some sort.
You might say,
well,
you decided that yourself and answer
that.
It's like no,
wrong.
You haven't decided that you yourself,
are you kidding?
You'd be at a complete psychopath if
you'd decided that by yourself,
right?
I mean,
if you're even the Vegas civilized,
then you decide what it is that you
should do or what you should do manifest
itself within you as a context of a
dialogue that you're continually having
with yourself,
but also with everyone around you.
And not only only with everyone around
you,
but with the entire kit history of
mankind.
Because we're all historical creatures.
And you know,
what you think you should do is being
shaped by what your parents think.
And there that was shaped by what their
parents thought,
that was shaped by what their parents
thought.
And so on,
back into the depths of history as far
back as you can possibly imagine,
both historically and biologically.
So in some sense there is a call to
action within people now,
you know,
in any sort of quest story,
like the Hobbit,
let's say,
um,
or the Lord of the rings for that
matter.
You know,
the story always starts with,
with a call to action,
right?
For some reason or another,
the little hobbit character,
which by the way is you,
you know,
the hobbits live in this little
protected place and they're not very big
and they're not very smart and they
don't know about the wide world beyond
them,
where the great forces of good and evil
are at combat.
And one hobbit who's a little bit more
adventurous than the rest gets called to
act,
gets called upon to act.
And in,
in the heartbeat stories,
it's usually the wizard who manages it,
right?
So it's a magical figure of some sort
who's extraordinarily wise and
extraordinarily old,
who might as well be gone for all
intents and purposes,
who says,
you know,
it's time for you to go and become a
thief.
Well,
that's what happens in the Hobbit,
right?
It's very weird thing because obviously
that's Frodo,
right?
Photos,
the hobbit in,
in the hobbit.
And Bilbo is the hobbit and the Lord of
the rings,
if I remember correctly,
the way around Bilbo is the hobbit in
the hobbit.
Fine Bill.
Okay,
so bill will gets called to action and
he's gonna go,
he's gonna go find a dragon while the
dragon is the same thing.
That swallow joke,
it's the same story and the Jew and the
dragon has a treasure,
which is a weird thing.
It's like what's up with dragons,
right?
What did they hoard?
Virgin.
That's the Saint George Story.
It's a very,
very old story or goal.
And that's weird behavior for a
predatory lizard.
But anyways,
you accept that without any problems.
Of course,
a dragon lives underground and a big
mountain that was excavated by doors and
sits on the treasure.
It's like we go to,
we don't have any problem with that
idea.
Well,
why fate?
I mean really,
you really believe that and answer as
well.
Well enough to read the damn book and to
make the,
I mean,
how many people went and watched the
Lord of the Rings?
How many people?
And think about it worldwide.
How much money did a Harry Potter
generate?
You know,
I bet you a Harry Potter generated more
money then the remaining steel mills in
Britain,
if you calculated across the amount of
time since those stories emerged.
Right.
So of course there's a lizard in a
predatory lizard and Harry Potter too.
It's the thing that skitters around
underneath hogwarts and turns you to
stone with the glance of an eye.
Oh,
and does that Lizard Hoard Virgins?
Okay.
Well what's the name of the woman that
the girl that he,
uh,
kidnaps Jenny.
Right.
Okay.
What's the word?
Ginny from Virginia.
Right.
Good.
She's Harry's first love interest and
he,
he rescues her from the damn snake and
he gets parallels,
won't paralyzed while he's doing it.
What rescues Harry.
Okay.
Phoenix.
Right?
A Phoenix.
Okay.
So the bass of this cause bites Harry
and so he's going to die.
The Phoenix comes along.
Who owns the Phoenix?
Dumbledore.
Yeah.
What does the Phoenix do?
Cries and cries into Harry's wounds.
Yes.
But what happens then?
What happens to Harry?
He comes back to life,
death and resurrection story.
So the thing that's willing to die and
resurrect is the thing that gets the
virgin from the snake.
It's like,
does that make sense?
Well you think it makes sense even
though you don't really know why it
makes sense.
And then what happens to the,
what happens to the Phoenix after it
does that
Burns itself up in a puff of flame and
is reborn.
So it's the story told twice.
The thing that dies in his reporting is
the thing that conquers the,
the serpentine and rescues the feminine,
roughly speaking.
So it's not gold in that situation,
but it doesn't matter.
It's the same story.
It's always the same story.
So,
and when you don't hear that story,
like when your culture isn't providing
you with rich stories of that sort,
that are derived directly from your
tradition.
Somebody like an unemployed welfare
mother in Britain has it pop up full
fledged in her brilliant imagination and
lays out seven books and makes herself
more money than the queen.
Right?
Right.
And that,
you know,
it's a cinderella story.
It's a bloody amazing story.
And then there's all those books and all
those kids learn to read because of the
books.
And then there's all those movies and
everybody goes and sees them and no one
notices that they don't know what the
hell they're doing while they're doing
it.
And it follows the same old story.
All right?
So you've got your individual that's
you,
the hero,
then you got the adversary to that.
That's your enemy.
Wherever that enemy might happen to me,
that's the forces that oppose oppose
you,
but mostly psychological forces of one
form or another.
Then you've got the father.
Well,
there's two kinds of fathers.
What kind of good fathers and bad
fathers?
So here's an example.
Um,
the lion king,
so the lion king as a father,
right?
Uh,
the Fossa and the Fossa has a brother
who his brother scar.
And what's up with scar?
Not a pleasant guy.
Partly maybe because he's scarred
something's hat.
Well,
really he's kind of skinny.
He said he came from the shallow end of
the gene pool.
Obviously something's happened to him
because he has this scar.
He's arrogant and brilliant,
which is very common set of attributes
for negative father figures and he's out
to do in the cake.
Right?
So what does he represent?
Well,
you could say,
here's a way of thinking about it
sociologically.
One of the things you hear very
frequently,
I'm sure many of you have heard this ad
Nauseum,
is that there's such a thing as the
patriarchy,
right?
The patriarchy,
while,
okay,
the pet patriarchy is a mythological
construct.
And I mean that,
I mean that technically speaking,
you have a paternal figure that
basically represents,
it could represent the father directly
or it can represent the structure of
male power.
It's not just male power.
But what if for the time being,
we'll,
we'll stick with that.
It has a positive aspect,
which is why you get to sit here and
you're not being snowed on and freezing
to death.
So that's the positive element.
And it has a negative element.
And the negative element is the
arbitrary tyranny that's associated with
any social organization.
Right.
So,
okay.
What do you think of the u of t like
your first year?
Did you enjoy it?
How many people didn't enjoy it.
Okay.
How many people did enjoy it?
All right.
So more by the looks of things,
some of you and some of you are neutral,
you'd either enjoyed it or,
or didn't to join or you don't have the
mental energy to crank.
So,
okay.
So most he didn't enjoy it.
What the hell are you doing here?
They're like,
what?
Why bother?
So someone who didn't enjoy it and it's
answered me that maybe you really didn't
enjoy it,
but here you are.
Why are you still here?
That's the sunk cost answered.
It's like you,
you waited for a bus for half an hour.
It hasn't showed up.
Did the right thing to do is wait for
another half an hour.
Right.
Um,
I,
well,
to put it in the more medical over to
him,
I approached it from a different angle.
So basically I changed when I was
studying.
Oh.
How'd that work worked out?
Well,
was it the second time?
I did try it.
It worked out well.
Good,
good.
So was that an unpleasant process?
Were you confused?
Did you come out the other end?
Um,
yeah,
right on.
Good work.
You're more mature,
you know more than you did five years
ago.
I hope so.
Was it worth it?
All right.
Good.
Good for you.
Well,
look,
you make a calculation.
Hey,
what's wrong with the University of
Toronto?
Well,
there's 60,000 students for a starter.
Like what the Hell do you matter?
You know,
really your numbered and it feels like
that a lot of the time.
You know?
And so it's a very impersonal
institution and you're sort of tossed
into it.
So you're basically facing a giant of
some magnitude who's kind of blind and
who sort of archaic,
which is always what culture is,
right?
Culture's always blind because it's a
product of yesterday and it's,
and it's archaic.
It's not up to date.
So you're going to have a problem with
it and you have that problem when you
come to the university.
So you stick with it though because
it's,
it's got two faces.
One face is sink or swim there guys.
And the other face is,
man,
if you're careful than you and establish
a relationship with this kind of
institution,
you can learn so much that you won't
even be the same person when you come
out.
Maybe you'll be able to think that'd be
good.
You know,
if you learn to think,
then you don't run into sharp things
when you wander through life because
you're smart enough to see where they
are and avoid them.
You know,
and maybe you can think your way to a
target or maybe you can even think about
a target that's worthwhile and you can
figure out how to attain it.
And maybe you learn to write and then
you can articulate your ideas and you
can express them with some power and you
can make,
you know,
you can be a positive force in the world
and you can be successful in all sorts
of ways.
And if you have to put up with being
tyrannized by,
uh,
you know,
half dad monster with,
with Alzheimer's disease,
that's blind,
well that's life.
And it could be a lot worse because at
least you're contending with something
that has a positive element.
You know,
in lots of societies if you're up
against the,
the the blind giant of society,
the best that you can hope for is that
it isn't running around trying to stomp
on you all the time.
And I would say that's more the standard
human experience.
So yeah,
there's a patriarch and yes,
negative,
obviously it's always been like that.
But by the same token,
you know,
there's good guy embedded in that too.
And that's the thing you want to have a
relationship with.
And that's the same old story.
It's always been like that.
There's always a wise king in a tyrant
and they're always fighting.
And sometimes the wise king king wins,
sometimes the tyrant winds and then when
the tire,
when it's up to the hero to defeat the
tyron and reestablish the rightful king.
And that's actually what you're trying
to do when you're in university because
the rightful king in some sense is a
corpse that's embedded inside the
university.
And your job is to reverify it,
you know,
you're the living element of the
university and all the knowledge is
dead.
It's just lying around and some of it's
out of date.
You know,
you come in here and you,
you revive it so that society can
continue and so that you can benefit
from the relationship.
Well that's the positive and negative.
Great.
Farther the wise king and the tyrant.
And then another,
another level is the feminine.
The Feminine is not women.
Women partake of the feminine and the
masculine,
just like men partake of the feminine
and the masculine.
But the maternal element,
the feminine elements is nature.
Positive nature.
Well that's the thing that the
environmentalist,
it's love,
right?
That's flowers and French landscapes and
you know,
pleasant days,
picnic in the park and and beautiful
sunshine and fresh air and clean water.
But then there's another side.
Another side is,
do you know what the Guinea worm is?
Does anybody know what a Guinea worm is?
Well,
I'm going to tell you,
although you're not going to be happy
about it.
So a Guinea worm is this horrible
parasite that burrows under the skin,
mostly of children,
mostly in Africa,
and it's about two feet long.
So it makes these coils around their
legs and then it'll poke its little head
out and then you can pull it out.
But it tends to break.
And if that happens then it gets
infected.
It may be you die and so you can wrap it
around a pencil very slowly and pull it
out.
That's nature.
Now there's a doctor who's a Canadian
doctor who wasn't reading very happy
about those damn getting worms and he's
just about eradicated them and like
hooray for him.
But you know,
when we're talking about the
environment,
especially when we're thinking about it
and mythological categories and we're
talking about nature,
it's like,
yeah,
it's nature and all its beneficial
glory,
but it's also all the things that would
just as soon eat you in the most awful
possible way.
And you need to know that too,
because if you think of nature as only
beneficial and it's positive
archetypical element,
that that's mother nature in all her
glory,
then you tend to denigrate the utility
of the positive elements of culture.
You know,
it's culture that protects you from the
horrible elements of nature.
You wouldn't even be able to think about
nature is beautiful if you weren't
already so protected from it.
You know,
you're more protected from it than any
human beings ever have been anywhere in
the entire history of life.
And so in this unbelievably protected
environment,
you can think,
oh well we should go easy on nature
because isn't it so beautiful?
It's like,
yeah,
well,
yes and no.
And it's not all beauty.
It's certainly not because nature will
eventually kill you.
So it's even if it doesn't go well,
it's going to kill you.
It will also make you sick.
It will also make everyone that you know
sick and it will kill all of them too.
So it's not so such a bad thing to have
a little bit of empathy for human beings
given that we have to contend with that.
And you know,
if we're destroying everything,
which we're not,
it's also returning the favor.
So,
all right,
so there's the sub strategy at the
bottom of things.
There's this terrible monster,
but it hoards ghoul.
And so encountering it,
defeating it,
challenging it,
facing it can be unbelievably
productive.
And that's the symbol of the absolute
unknown.
That's where you go when things fall
apart.
You don't know where you are.
So where are you?
You're aware you don't know what things
are.
And that's a place.
And what's interesting about it is that
there are rules to act in that place.
And that's what's so helpful because you
know,
if you're in a place and you don't know
what to do and that's that your die.
But if there's a pattern to what you can
do in a circumstance like that,
then in the land on your feet and you're
ready to contend,
and maybe the trip down into the
underworld is something you can
undertake on your own accord.
And you can come back with the treasurer
and steadying instead of ending up as
dragon food or worse.
And then when you're conceptualizing
your relationship to other people,
well,
well let's say the society,
first of all,
it's like,
yeah,
obviously you face a tyrant.
Of course you do.
But that is all you face.
And you need to be grateful for what
you've been given by your culture.
And you actually have to understand what
that culture is because it's you.
And if you don't rescue that part of
you,
and that part of the culture that
everything gets dead and stale and
tyrannical and everything goes
immediately to help.
And that's not a good thing.
And then with regards to nature,
well,
you obviously have to appreciate the
positive element of nature and you have
to enter into a relationship with it,
but you don't bloody well want to forget
that.
Like things are out to get you.
And you know,
you have to be intelligent and,
and ready and awake so that you can
prevail against that.
And you have to be grateful for what
you've been offered by other people.
And by the tremendous efforts of all of
human culture across all of the time,
it's putting you in a position where you
are so unbelievably privileged and have
so many opportunities at your,
at your disposal.
Well,
so that's kind of the archetypal story
of human beings.
We always face nature and it's always on
our pho aside.
We always face our culture.
It's always on our side and we always
have ourselves and those things that are
arrayed against us internally,
externally.
And that's the,
you could say that's the existential
world.
It's the world of drama and the things
that are really compelling to you as
means of communicating.
Use those categories to provide you with
information because what,
what you're trying to figure out is if
that's the landscape that makes up your
being,
that's a phenomenological idea.
How is it that you weave your way
through it?
While that's what we're going to figure
out?
Well,
we go through this class.
Okay,
so that's the mythological background.
So there's the character or logical
elements that I just described and then
there's the punctuated movement forward.
Now,
you know,
the problem with that is that when
things fall apart,
it's not like you just fall apart
psychologically.
It's not just a psychological condition.
You know,
if someone's be trade you deeply,
that might be because you're naive and
unready and maybe that's a psychological
element.
Maybe you're just young and you know you
don't know better and you couldn't.
But there's also the real fact of the
problem that you have in fact been
betrayed and now you don't know what to
do.
So there's reality in it as well as just
what psychological.
And so
one of the things that you might,
one of the ways that you might construe
personality theories that have to deal
with a description of the way people are
and a description of how they might move
towards mental health is that there are
maps that tell you how to their maps of
that landscape that tell you how to
Orient Yourself so that you can succeed
and even better.
And this is a Ph jetty and idea.
It's not only so that you can succeed,
it's so that you can succeed in a way
that your family succeed.
So that they can succeed in a way that
society succeeds so that everything
works better at the same time.
And that's really success,
you know?
And that's like you're winning a game
that everyone wants to play.
Well,
what a deal.
You get to move forward and everyone
else gets to enjoy it.
While that's a good definition of
success,
it's an archetypal definition of success
actually,
because if you succeed property,
then your success benefits everyone
else.
So hard to imagine that there could be
anything particularly wrong with that.
All right,
so
that's the mythological element.
Now I want to tell you a little bit
about the shamonic element.
Now
the reason I want to talk to you about
shamanism is because of shamanism is a
very,
very old phenomenon and the Shaman
isn't,
looks like a phenomenon that involves
the dramatization of transformation
processes.
So,
so one transformation process might be
the initiation of young men.
Now it's more typical for young men to
be initiated,
then young women.
And no one really knows why that is,
except men seem to be able to go more
spectacularly wrong than women.
So well,
so if you look at what,
we will talk about that later.
But there's also competing theories that
say you don't have to initiate women
because nature does that all by itself.
And I think that that's not a
particularly bad way of looking at it.
So women are going to be confronted with
the brute force of nature,
but men can either do that or not do it.
And so there's in some sense an element
of choice.
And so the initiation rituals take away
the element of choice.
And so on a typical initiation ritual,
what happens is that young men usually
at the onset of puberty or taken away
from their familial dependence,
which really means their mothers,
and then they're put into some situation
and terrified three quarters to death.
Now more or less,
they do that voluntarily.
So perhaps here's an example,
maybe you're 13 so remember,
think about your 13 think about that.
Okay?
And so you're still afraid of the dark
when you're 13 even though they'll tell
people that you aren't.
But you are.
And so like if you were dropped naked in
the middle of a forest when you're 13
and it's midnight,
you're going to be plenty frozen with
terror and a good thing too,
because you know it's dangerous out
there.
Okay.
So then you think,
well,
maybe it's just a park,
but you're still out there and it's dark
and you're afraid.
You might say,
well,
what are you afraid of?
And one of the things you might come up
with as well,
you're afraid of what you're imagining.
And then you might say,
well,
does that mean that you're afraid of
your imagination or are you afraid of
the things your imagination represents?
Well,
you kind of have to think if there's no
actual objective danger there,
then what you're afraid of is your
imagination.
Now,
did you guys ever see the Blair witch
project?
How many of you've seen that?
How many of you haven't know?
So it's a pretty lousy example.
Anyways,
it's a horror movie.
Now there's kind of two kinds of horror
movies.
There's the splatter type horror movie
and I think actually those expose you to
discuss and then there's the fear kind
of horror movie.
And that doesn't need to have any Gore
at all.
It just makes you afraid.
And the Blair witch project is a very
good example of that because all that
happens,
nothing happens,
nothing happens.
But you think something terrible is
going to happen every second.
And the sense that something terrible is
going to happen keeps climbing through
the whole movie.
And so what they do is put you in a
state of radical uncertainty and never
let you off.
Okay,
well,
so basically they're playing with your
imagination and that can work very
effectively.
Like it's often a horror movies often
more effective if they don't show you
what's making those horrible noises off
screen,
you know,
because no matter what,
show you the probability that it can be
as personally horrible as what are their
monsters you're dredging up out of your
imagination is very low.
So,
okay.
And you know,
it's reasonable to be afraid of the dark
because throughout our biological
history,
lots of unfortunate people were devoured
by things in the dark or hurt very badly
by them,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And we're also daytime creatures,
right?
So we don't like the dark very much.
So
what do you do to someone if you're
going to initiate them is maybe you take
them when they're 13 and you put them in
a really dark cave and caves.
There are so dark man,
like if you're in a cave,
you just can't believe how dark it is.
It's,
it's,
you can't see anything in a cave.
So you don't know how big this space
you're in is and you don't know how
small it is and you don't know whether
or not it's going to collapse or when
it's going to stay on.
And you don't know how far you are
underground,
especially if the people who took you
there didn't,
you know,
walked around in circles and didn't let
you know where you're going and then
maybe they leave and maybe they leave
for three days.
And so you're sitting down there
thinking,
well,
what are you thinking exactly?
Well,
you're thinking the most horrible
thoughts you could possibly imagine,
right?
I'm never going to get out of here.
They're never going to find me again.
Some horrible snake thing that lives in
the dark.
This is going to come and eat me slowly
because fast would be,
you know,
merciful and I'm,
and then I'm also going to go completely
out of my mind so that even if something
doesn't eat me,
I'm going to come out of here.
It will be worse than being dead
anyways.
And so partly what you're doing in that
circumstances,
you're facing the demons of your own
imagination.
And if you can stand that,
then you grow up.
And that's what an initiation ceremony
does.
Now,
a lot of what you'll find if you look at
clinical theories of psychology,
the same motif applies.
If you want to get better,
you have to find out what you're
avoiding and what you're afraid of and
maybe what you're disgusted by evil.
And you have to expose yourself to that
voluntarily and you have to let that
change you.
And so it's not a pleasant prospect.
I mean it's not dancing through a field
of daisies,
right?
With music play and it's not follow your
bliss.
You know,
it's not the natural unfolding of a
positive process.
It's not that at all.
It's the voluntary confrontation with
the things that make up life's horrors.
But what's interesting about it is that
there's,
there's an idea there that lurks under
the surface architecturally,
and that is,
there's a lot more to you than meets the
eye,
but it won't be released unless it has
to.
And so you're not going to even figure
out what it is until you put yourself in
peril.
Now part of that,
you might think like,
imagine that you're,
you're an introvert,
you're socially awkward,
you're hiding your audit so you feel a
lot of anxiety and depression.
You don't like going to parties.
And that's because the horrible pirate
lives at parties and always glaring at
you and judging you and telling you how
useless an insufficient you are.
And so you go there and you don't even
look at people because you know that if
you did look at them,
you just see the face of the judgmental
tyrant,
which by the way,
you wouldn't if you actually looked at
them,
but you won't because you avoid.
And so you're going to go there and
you're gonna put yourself in this
terrible situation.
And if you're lucky and you're a bit of
weight,
then you're going to incorporate all
sorts of information from the external
world that will help you develop your
social skills and make you more
sophisticated.
And even if that doesn't happen,
you're going to learn that you can
tolerate your own fear.
And you might say,
well,
what's better to not be afraid or to
know that you can handle being afraid
and obviously to not be afraid,
but give that up cause that ain't
happening.
So the,
the next best thing and the realistic
thing is to know that you're the master
of your own fear.
And so a lot of what we're going to talk
about in relationship to classical
theories of personality is exactly that.
It's not that the world isn't terrible,
he that the world is terrible,
but you're a lot stronger than you think
and the way you,
okay.
And so part of that is the strength that
you gathered is partly the information
that you gathered when you go somewhere
that you're not good at.
You know,
so you were establishing new skills like
you have at university,
but there's another part that's
interesting that's related to the little
video that I showed you at the
beginning.
DNA turns out to be very complex
structure.
And so if I put you in situation a,
then DNA codes,
certain kinds of proteins that help make
up the way that your mind is in the way
it works.
But if I take you and I put you in
another situation,
completely different genes turn on.
And so what that means is that you have
a biological repository of potential use
lime and Patrick at the highest
resolution level of your molecular
structure.
And then if you push yourself and all
sorts of different directions and you
find different things to pursue and test
yourself against,
then you're going to turn on parts of
yourself that aren't currently on and
God only knows what you'd be like if you
turned yourself completely on.
Maybe I could use a better metaphor.
Okay.
I'll tell you a little bit more about
the Shavano routines because they're
more,
you know,
if there's a initiation archetype,
which are kind of just described to you,
which is you can do this for yourself.
I'll tell they're all your house,
then this is a good way to live.
Beats the alternative anyway.
So,
which is like the definition of a good
way to live so mad and you're trying to
pursue something so you've got a goal.
That's a good thing.
You got to have a goal and you don't
want to hold on to that too tightly
because you might be wrong.
It's,
you've gotta be willing to let that go
and have a different goal,
but you need a goal.
And then you know,
while you're pursuing goal,
you're going to find out that there's
some obstacles in your path,
obviously.
And maybe some of those obstacles are of
a frightening tight,
maybe the reason of a disgusting tight,
you might say,
I don't want to turn it into that kind
of person.
So those of you who are sort of
socialist utopia had left wingers might
think that way about business people.
It's like,
I wouldn't,
I would recommend that you get over it
as rapidly as possible.
So anyways,
you might think there's no way I'm going
to act that way.
So you sort of put it off limits,
say it.
Or maybe you are afraid to do what you
need to do next.
Well,
here's the rule.
Don't avoid doing things because they
make you feel negative emotion.
If you have to do those things in order
to pursue your balls,
in fact,
you should do exactly the opposite.
So let's say you're pursuing a goal and
you find that you're afraid about
something and so you're avoiding it.
The first thing you should think is,
Aha,
look,
I'm afraid of something under,
I'm avoiding it.
Dragon treasure.
Exactly there.
And that's exactly right.
It's precisely right.
If you're,
if you're afraid of the thing,
then what that means is that you're not
developed enough to handle it and you
need to be.
So you should think about that as a
discovery,
like a positive discovery.
You found out where you have a weakness
and you're now able to address it.
So,
you know,
if you're an introvert and you think
it's Friday night,
I could go to this party,
but you know,
I really don't want to.
But then you think,
oh,
that means I should go.
And that's exactly right because,
yeah,
because you already know how to do the
things that you know how to do.
And it's the things that you don't know
how to do that bother you and oppress
you.
And of course those things are going to
be difficult to learn about,
but you need to learn about them because
you need to get yourself all switched
on.
How's that switched on?
Because then you'll be able to tolerate
the fact that life is fundamentally
suffering and so you don't do,
world doesn't get safer.
US,
you've developed,
in fact,
quite the contrary.
You just get more competent and that's
been her anyways because it's
conceivable that you don't want safety
anyways.
You probably want adventure.
You probably want to be compelled.
You probably want to be engaged.
You know,
if you want security,
you might as well be dead well because
nothing's happening then and that
there's no danger to be alive is to be
contending with the,
with the world and you want to be the
basket that you can possibly be.
And that's partly what we're going to
learn about as we go through the entire
course.
But certainly the elements that have to
do with clinical psychology because all
of them circulate around this
fundamental fee.
They have to because it's the
fundamental story of mankind.
And we want to know what that
fundamental story is because you're all
human and you need to know the story,
and then you know,
you can decide how you're going to act
it out,
but at least you need to know the damn
story first.
So
we'll see you.